ah que depuis excepté au royaume uni
avec bharat pente cagna il est expert en
maladies infectieuses c'est notre
rubrique vu de l'extérieur baraquements
cagna merci d'être en direct avec nous
sur rt france alors on le disait lio
l'orne se re consignes pour six semaines
pourtant l'organisation mondiale de la
santé des conseils leur confinement
quelle est votre position sur cette
question est ce que c'est la bonne
stratégie adoptée par l'irlande livre
ait échoué et la stratégie seul même si
enfin tirer un enseignement c'est à dire
est qu'il faut préparer une stratégie de
sortie
il faut savoir ce qu'il faut réparer
dans le système il faut le réparer et
qu'ensuite il faut appliquer le
confinement et ensuite en sortir
correctement c'est extrêmement important
la stratégie de donc être penser à ce
qu'on va faire après les six semaines de
confinement alors en confinement mais
les écoles restent ouvertes selon le
premier ministre irlandais michael
martin c'est parce que je cite nous ne
pouvons pas nous permettre que l'avenir
de nos enfants et de nos jeunes soit une
autre victime de cette maladie vous
partager ce constat il faut laisser les
écoles ouvertes en irlande il rappela à
ce qu il faut que les écoles ouvertes où
il faut trouver d'autres façons de
maintenir l'enseignement
mais si les écoles restent fermées
d'autres instituts le reste rien ne
s'agit donc pas d'un confinement complet
les nombres de cas des sera donc mais ne
laissera pas beaucoup plus en tout cas
les nombres de cabas serait beaucoup
plus si les écoles avec est également
fermée c'est un acte d'équilibriste
il serait mieux d'enseigner à domicile à
l'humain si ce n'est pas possible
alors le nombre de cas ne baissera pas
autant qu'on pourrait l'espérer alors
une décision sanitaire mais c'est aussi
pour tenter de sauver les fêtes de noël
selon vous à haïti n'goran ne cesse pas
de gps effectivement que c'est le cas et
ils pensent à l'avenir mais nous sommes
déjà phantom et avec autant de nouveaux
cadres dans l'europe
les hommes et femmes politiques qui
doivent d'être honnête elle sincère avec
la population et leur dire que nous à
2020 sera différent de celui des autres
années on ne pourra pas avoir le noël
habituel cette année sera différente
parce que le virus est très présent dans
les communautés c'est difficile et cela
causera des problèmes s'il y avait de
grands rassemblements lors de la période
de noël alors sur le front de la
recherche 1 pour un vaccin
des chercheurs britanniques ont annoncé
aujourd'hui qu'ils comptaient infecter
des volontaires de 18 à 30 ans avec le
nouveau coronavirus pour faire avancer
la recherche dans le cadre d'une étude
de l'inrs perial college de londres
est ce que c'est une piste intéressante
qu est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire
cela fait partie de la phase 3 des
essais l'expérimentation n'immunisent
est des volontaires on lis beaucoup
c'est très important il faut il miser
des jeunes des personnes âgées des
personnes souffrance des personnes
vulnérables
il faut immunisés tous les secteurs de
la population et ensuite il faut avoir
un groupe de comparaison des jeunes des
personnes d'âge moyen des personnes qui
ont des problèmes et ensuite il faut
comparer les deux groupes et voir si
elle a le médicament injecté a fait une
différence positive et s'il n'y a pas
d'effets secondaires qu'il y ait une
différence positive alors on sait que le
vaccin est réussi et qu'on peut essayer
de le faire autoriser donc c'est la
procédure d'autorisation d'un vaccin
dans des groupes importants alors qu
observer vous
sur l'évolution de l'épidémie depuis le
début comment est-ce que cette deuxième
va commencer cette deuxième vague ce à
quoi on peut s'attendre dans les
prochaines semaines sur des centrales et
prédictible
tout était prévisible mais vais rien de
nouveau et que toute personne avec la
moindre reconnaissance en épidémiologie
vous expliquerez que lorsqu'on sort de
confinement est que le virus est
toujours temps la communauté et qu'on
n'applique pas d avertissement est très
stricte interdisant par exemple comme
socialisation importante alors le nombre
de cas repart à la hausse
effectivement le nombre de cas est
reparti à la hausse et nous sommes
maintenant dans une période plus froide
les gens sont plus rassemblé les écoles
les universités et sont restées ouvertes
tous ces facteurs sont que le nombre de
cas augmenter
c'était prévisible nous le savions mais
les hommes politiques n'aiment pas
évoquer ce sujet et au royaume uni
nouvelles restrictions aussi en pleine
deuxième vague également comment est-ce
que se déroule la politique des tests in
uk oui à tweeté au royaume et moi il ya
trois échelons moyens eelv est très
élevé certaines régions sont soumises à
un confinement une scripte les le
royaume uni est très densément peuplées
beaucoup de personnes vivent dans des
espaces très réduits
il est donc très difficile d'avoir une
région comme liverpool ou est les
restrictions sont très sévères et à côté
tout à côté une région à moins de 30 km
de là où les restrictions sont plus
souples
nous savons que la situation va être
très difficile à contrôler et qu'il
faudrait peut-être traiter la situation
avec les régions plus large qui
observerait les mêmes restrictions
le royaume uni a
également besoin d'appliquer la
politique de tests et de traçage sinon
nous aurons encore des départs et des
arrêts brutaux
merci beaucoup baratte que scania pour
votre éclairage rappelle que vous êtes
expert en maladies infectieuses